days of a a a company using one data
center one partner partner and one
technology a provider has obviously gone
way way but what we're what what we're
gonna see for companies like global. is
a huge opportunity to allow a companies
to benefit from what we've able to
achieve in terms of both serving our
clients and our vendors
and helping it to for them to to develop
their business further
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet you
val rachlin ceo of global dots
yuval is a technology entrepreneur
living and breathing the tech world for
over 25 years he is the founder and ceo
of global dots a global web and cloud
technology partner helping companies
embrace innovation for over 70 years now
trusted by over 400 global enterprises
including lufthansa bosch wix platika
appsflyer payoneer and more providing
them access and support for the most
cutting edge technologies out there
yuval resides in israel he is married
with two kids and a dog and as a
seasoned skipper you've all enjoyed
sailing traveling cooking and music
yuval rocklin welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm good michael
thank you for inviting me it's great to
be here thank you very very much for
joining me and we're going to be talking
about you know the tech world and not a
specific company not a specific vertical
but this idea of transitioning into a
tech world all around us you know pretty
much every company in the last few years
is realized big or small that they need
to make this dramatic transition
dramatic mainly because it's really
complicated there's a lot of trends
there's a lot of new technologies a lot
of processes and with global dots you
you make it easier and you help them do
this so tell me a little bit about
yourself and then we'll dive deep into
what globaldox does
all right so basically i've started this
business uh many many years ago actually
and it all started
basically
with
me and not having a job i was living in
italy back then
and i didn't have a job i had to do
something and i knew about this very
cool technology actually one of the best
one of the first implementation of cloud
usage
and um
i knew people who could use it and uh
and in this company you know it was many
many years ago so it made sense but this
company didn't sell in italy and later
on i realized they didn't sell anywhere
else besides the us and some other
locations which is common in the
industry nobody you know nobody is
thought something else and but what i
did is that i i went to this company and
was i was able to convince them and to
cover some territories for them
and it went very well
and if i
move fast forward 20 years basically
that's what we've been doing in the last
20 years and looking for those cool
upcoming disruptive technology
technologies and helping both those
startups getting quicker into market as
well as are a
client say adopting those technologies
and
so that's that's you know that's that's
where i started and where i am now
global lots now it's a is a global
company around 100 employees around the
world from san francisco to tokyo with
the clients
with large
clients
from all around the world and basically
what we're helping them is
adopting new technologies and as we know
since we started here in the last 20
years the world of technology just
evolved in in a in a hyper scaling way
and the problem always was the same
if i'm a cto a ciso a a technology
leader
it's not my job to go out there and keep
track of what's happening now in the
market and
and and what i need to use because i
would not do my job if i'll do that
later on if i find this
you know now it's obvious everybody
knows it nobody has the human force or
the experience to actually do this so
that's where we come into play we
actually
um
introduce new technologies that help
companies break their barriers and help
them implement it support it and manage
it that's what
we're doing for our for our global
customers and that's who we are just to
make sure that you know the the idea is
clear can you give me a specific example
of you know perhaps a company you don't
even have to mention the name but
specifically you know a company or an
instance where you know global dots
comes in and and changes the way the
company thinks or integrates with new
technologies
we have many many examples i'll i'll
pick only one which comes into my mind
um and that i think this example
demonstrates the gap in the industry
between what companies
can do and what vendors can reach and
what's missing in between at the early
days of uh internet fraud and i think it
was ten maybe
eight years ago and
the the the um
the solutions around the scraping and
and both protection was very were very
very early in the market we recognized
that there was a sector a vertical in
the market that really suffers from this
and we actually in in in a very little
time were able to take a couple of
companies that were specializing in this
and
and actually implement those solutions
in like i think it was 10 euro european
airlines in in a year
and and this for the airlines it was a
savior because they were struggling with
the right solution they didn't know what
to do they were trying to to implement
several solutions and we came and solve
it for the vendors who could not
approach those clients it was a
basically we delivered those projects
and with no hassle and no investment on
their side and so that's a good example
of it and we do you know basically we do
it every day and the whole day yes but
that's the example that might resonate
better so what is really the pain point
that we're observing here you're taking
you know
examples of companies that are you know
struggling to make the sleep right into
the technology will be perhaps even try
and they fail
what what are the different challenges
that global dots and you as the leader
of blocks have are realizing as you're
building and continuing to grow the
company who are incredible with more
than 100 people what what is the the
really the pain point in the market
right now
so i think uh there are two two uh um
several main platforms for the for the
um clients for the users it's picking up
the right technology definitely
we all know
that technologies change
very quickly but we cannot adopt a new
infrastructure every year so we need to
make a good decision you know you use
they used to say you cannot be fired if
you buy ibm i don't know i think you're
too young to know this phrase do you
know it i i heard about it in the
history books
yeah so yeah it's it's from the 90s you
know i think it died in the 90s but
people used to say you cannot be fired
if you're buying bm today you know you
don't have a safe haven you don't have
it you really need to take a a a a good
decision a very very important decision
of what you will bet on which solution
will serve you for at least three to
five years so this is the first what
which technology to to use and the
second of course this is the largest the
biggest challenge now globally is who
would implement it and support it and
manage it there are no people with the
right
and
knowledge in the market and companies
are struggling to hire people and so
those are the two main er struggles for
the users
for the startups from the for the
technology vendors obviously
you know
there's a reason why they're all
investing millions of dollars in
um
in in in spinning up sales departments
from zero i'm not saying they shouldn't
of course they should that's their job
but until they do that it's a long
process it takes years to build a good
sales team until then they can use a
global dots who would really
shorten their time to market and would
expose them to important the use cases
that they would benefit from in in their
development
cycle what is the process that you have
to do as you enter a company
let's say i'm running a company and i
present my challenges to you what is
sort of the process that you're going to
go with me
as
we work on figuring out how you're going
to be work how you're going to be you
know implementing these solutions with
me
so you know first of all we are we're
doing obviously a deep study of of the
infrastructure we have a lot of tools
to examine what works what what doesn't
work what would be better we have a lot
of experience so we do a lot of uh uh um
digging around and we will let you
actually and that's the best i think we
will let you
choose from various options and and we
will let you try out
several options and this is something
that if you want to do a loan it will
take you
a a weeks
to deal with the sales people and the
whole process of those companies and we
can really bring up the pocs of the main
suspects very very quickly you have a
quick decision and and we move forward
so that's i think you know after the the
the study and the the digging into your
infrastructure which everybody would do
and we would line up a few candidates
that it would be easier for you to er
and to decide
now i'm looking i'm thinking correctly
about you know the companies that i'm
seeing around me and i'm thinking what i
would be
considerate of as you know as a leader
here and i think you mentioned you know
when you're talking about this idea of
diving into the infrastructure and
really understanding doing a deep dive
into the market i'm thinking to myself
well great well i i've been doing this
for years i have a team that's been
doing this with me for years
and who better to do that than we and i
think this raises the dilemma of you
know outsourced versus in-house so from
you from your experience now working
with many many clients
you know where is this consideration
what how do we actually weigh these two
things
yeah it's always it's always the case
for companies like ourselves and it's
getting better because people an i.t
department cannot hire
a and the talent is very very uh
not common right now
and there's a big
um
there's a big competition every a
a job
and it's a it's a it's an employer's
market so uh sometimes
it's sometimes some sometimes something
that they cannot move forward with
without external help because you know
if it's if it's a subject that we
learned in the last five years
they will never find a someone out there
in the market that would know it and it
would take them time to to learn so
first of all they all acknowledge the
fact that they can learn from our
experience
and and from the fact that we have seen
all the use cases
and we've seen the use cases for their
competitors and we are able to
to shorten the time to get a good
decision so that's a that's why so you
know you can do it in-house
it will cost you a more it will take
more time and we will probably then
that's the main thing you will be very
quickly biased by things that are a less
professional
it's you know
organizations have their own
dna and their own processes
and if you do it in-house you will never
reach optimal some some people are good
with that but if you take it out for
professionals you can show that you get
the right
technology in the right time the right
support and the right implementation
otherwise you need to deal with the
vendors directly you know that's also a
possibility it's just time consuming and
i imagine that a big part of the role
and at the end you know the goal is not
to just to complete the project
successfully but for all the parties to
be happy right and i'm sure that
communication plays a really big role
here what have you learned about how to
facilitate the communication with your
clients especially when it's regarding
things that you are obviously more
knowledgeable about yet they're the ones
who have a kpi that they need to meet at
the end of the day how do you manage the
communication around that
yeah so you know we're trying to
provide constant training to our
customers and this is part of our
of our day-to-day and doing workshops
allowing them to expand their knowledge
and and this would this helps us to also
communicate in a more i would say a
instructor
not nothing structural a um
in a more uh consultant a way
and it helps us
to to to to to
basically build a good communication and
trust with our customers and it's
something that helps
right of course
to wrap up some conversation about you
know about the domain and vertical
before i i want to get to know you
better
if you're looking at you know where
we're headed you know as a tech world as
an ecosystem you know as we're advancing
the rate of technology is changing
what's going to happen you know with
with a company like global dots or with
the ecosystem as a whole you know where
are we headed towards in terms of
enabling companies to to maximize their
potential in the ways that global dots
allows them to
so i think uh um
the global trend
of
um moving from on-prem to the cloud
in all services all across the world
whatever you you like
is a good
indication of the change that the market
is moving from
holding things inside into releasing and
enjoying the benefit of the scale of
others i think
we're going into a situation where a lot
of companies will use a lot of services
and in order to support those services
they would need a lot of partners some
of those partners are the vendors
themselves some of the partners would be
other partners that would unify some
other vendors and but this is where
we're going
the days of a a company using one data
center one partner partner and one
technology a provider has obviously gone
way way but what
what we're gonna see for companies like
global. is a huge opportunity to allow a
companies to benefit from what we've
able to achieve in terms of both serving
our clients and our vendors
and helping it to for them to to develop
their business further and then that
makes a lot of sense so taking back a
little bit yuval you know down memory
lane middle school elementary school
you're looking at yourself as an
entrepreneur
not even as an entrepreneur you're like
10 years old but what really
i was an entrepreneur don't be wrong
okay tell me about that
whatever entrepreneur were you at 10
years old
i was you know i think i can't remember
10 years old but you know that there are
i think it was earlier there are
experiences in life i'm sure you know it
the changes that you remember them that
they change you somehow and i'll tell
you a small and short story and on how i
became first of all a sales person and
later on an owner of a company who does
mainly sales
so i'm talking about the uh late 70s
my mother had a fiat 188 i don't know if
you even know the name fiat so i won't
even go further and
so and she wanted to sell it and there
were you know no cellular phone of
course no phones at all i think we were
the only ones we had a phone
so my mother goes out and she tells me
you want you know i put up an ad for the
car and if someone calls just answer and
give them you know tell them a little
bit
so someone calls and i pick up the phone
and i just you know i just talk to him i
saw that this car in this
in this first call i didn't notice it to
be honest but then i heard people
talking to you how you know how he stole
the car he saw the car slowly slowly i
got the the the the idea that you know
this is there's something i have
something that i that i can do to change
people's mind or at least i was certain
that i can do that and and this was a
you know i found myself focusing on
doing business
at the age of i think of 10 or 40 14 i
had already a
a network of agents selling door-to-door
basically you know i'm doing the same
what i'm doing what i'm doing now it's
exactly what i did then basically and so
you know that's that's what i did so i
was an entrepreneur back then and i knew
i was going to be an entrepreneur and
it was written all over my face
how did you end up then
starting global thoughts you knew that
this is a part of who you are but you
know where how does the story go that
you then decide okay there's actually a
big gap here and i can actually leverage
my sales
person my sales abilities while also
bridging the gap with their actual needs
so as i said in my you know when we
started to talk in in my first a a
anecdote when i was living in italy yeah
i realized that i was able to deliver
this promise of new technology for
companies who needed it and didn't hear
about it and this is where you know this
is where this gap
was was evident for me and and that's
where i started but did you know that
that you're going to be able to that
you're going to the vision is to build a
company that employs more than 100
people around the world to solve it i
understand the pain point in italy you
know saying that example but but there's
a big gap between seeing that pain point
to building a company that is running
for so many years with so many people no
i didn't i didn't have this uh it came
out along the way you know it was
evident along the way at the beginning
it was a one-man show then it was very
successful then you know i i saw the
opportunity then
then i hired more people and and turn it
out into a company i never thought it
would be a 100 a and a and i never and i
never thought we would reach the uh
the clients that we are serving and i
never thought that we would reach
the volumes that we are that we are
delivering so yeah um
i knew that i was an entrepreneur but i
didn't think that i would do it like
that
incredible incredible uh if you look
today i think very few people and
michael
really you know
they know envision exactly what they're
having and they know that they'll be an
inventor they'll know that they will be
i don't know a great professor
but they you know they don't know
exactly where they'll end but you know
and now if i were to ask
anybody
around you one of your 100 employees
and any of your clients who is you val
in a few words what words would come to
mind
i think they will stay creative they'll
stay calm and they'll say a thinker
creative common thinker amazing
thank you very very much for joining me
here it was mike
it was interesting to talk about you
know both your journey and the founding
of global dots but also this
understanding and the dilemma the
dissonance between outsource and
in-house and and the different
challenges that companies may have in
understanding what are the breadth of
opportunities that are out there
especially as you know every day that
goes by we have new technological
opportunities new challenges to overcome
in a never-ending globalized world as
with acceleration from this last year
and a half two years i think it's pretty
amazing and so thank you very very much
and stay safe thank you michael take
care thank you
[Music]